Welcome to week six in the Robotic Vision
Project. Just to recap, so far we've taken
an image of our Robotic Vision worksheet and
we've separated our shapes into a particular
colour, being either red, green or blue. We've
taken each 2D object and then classified it
in terms of a shape and a size. And we've
produce a homography to rectify these positions
into an X and Y Cartesian co-ordinate frame.
Now we can put all this together to form our
complete vision system.
Let's take a look now at the outputs of this in MATLAB.
Okay so in MATLAB here, I have the four different
functions that you've had to write throughout
the different weeks of the Robotic Vision
Project.
The first function that you needed to write
was called "getColor" and getColor returns
the binary image on a particular channel that
you're interested of the Robotic Vision worksheet,
so you could get a red binary image a green
binary image and a blue binary image.
That binary image was then fed into the next
function that we wrote, which was called "getShape"
and how getShape worked is that, that found
for us the particular 2D object in the binary
image that we were interested in, so we could
find either a circle, square or a triangle
and a different size; being either small or
large. The next function that we wrote was
called "getCalibration". Now how getCalibration
worked was that that was a function that allowed
us to find the blue circles on the Robotic
Vision worksheet page and that returned the
particular blobs, such that we know where
the centroids of those blobs were in our Robotic
Vision worksheet image.
The final function that we wrote was called
"getHomography" and getHomography took in
the centroid position of the blobs and also
we supplied it with the X and Y Cartesian
co-ordinates of the circles on our Robotic
Vision worksheet page and then that generated
a homography matrix such that we could rectify
the Robotic Vision worksheet, so we could
find the 2D object positions on the page.
Now I've wrapped up these four different functions
into a script which I've called "prac" so
let's run this script now and see what the
output of the project should look like. Okay
so this is the output from my prac script.
On the right hand side you can see that I
have my Robotic Vision worksheet image and
I've identified all of the red 2D objects;
so they're highlighted with a green rectangle,
so we have the red circles, the red squares
and the red triangles are all highlighted.
I've also identified the green 2D objects
and they are highlighted with a blue rectangle,
so we have the green circles here, the green
squares and the two green triangles. The blue
circles are the small ones have been identified
using a red asterisks, so eight of them have
been found and then finally we have our large
blue circle, which is highlighted with our
green asterisks.
On the left hand side we have the rectified
image, so from the calibration circles, I've
rectified it such that the X and Y Cartesian
axis is at the top left hand corner and that
allows us then to identify where the position
of the 2D objects are within this image and
I've printed all this information out to the
MATLAB workspace, so you can see here I have
the red 2D objects, and all the different
objects in the worksheet and also all the
green ones; I've not printed out the blue
circle positions at all.
And the columns here are the blob positions,
which are in pixels, so if I go back to this
image here, this is the pixel positions in
these columns and then on the right hand side
we have the final output of the Robotic Vision
Project.
So the Cartesian X and Y co-ordinate positions
in millimetres of all of the 2D objects. So
now you can compare your Cartesian X and Y
positions to what I've got and hopefully you've
got something quite similar to this.